[Music]
[Music]
all right it's so what would I put on a
billboard I could put one message on a
billboard to get to millions or billions
of people it would be you are the
average of the five people you associate
with most which also happens to be
probably the best advice that I received
between the ages of 10 and say 15 I
remember that a mentor at the time who I
think was borrowing from Jim Rohn ROA
Chen who happens to be the mentor of 20
Robbins long story but he left a message
on my answering machine with tapes
remember those kids and he left that bit
of advice to just remember you the
average of the five people you associate
with most right and that means
financially emotionally physically
mentally you are going to be the average
of the five people you spend the most
time around all right
so choose those people as well as you
can
hey guys if you're enjoying the tips and
tactics and how-to on this channel or in
the podcast the Tim Ferriss show I made
this for you
try the mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list 130 of
the best at what they do people who are
icons legends and ask them all the same
questions these are people in some cases
I wanted to reach out to my whole life
ranges from many many billionaires
cofounders of every company imaginable
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to powerlifting everything else
country stars actors directors and you
can spot the pattern so some of my
friends have said this is the easiest to
read most useful book that I've put
together yet so checking out tribal
mentors dot-com you can find sample
chapters the whole list of mentors
everything tribal mentors calm